do you think it's possible to have a
good conversation with each of them
Donald Trump and Joe Biden in a pot in a
podcast context or in a debate context
absolutely yeah you're saying like could
I with either of them oh 100 yeah Joe
Biden too sure
yeah look can you dig into that a little
more well I mean I don't know what I
think there's maybe something implicit
in your in your question but uh that's
deeper about the nature of politics and
politicians yes I think with either of
them I mean
the political differences wouldn't be an
impediment to having a good conversation
with either of them
um I think one of the things that's
really tough in my experience when
talking to elected officials is they
could be super interesting about a
hundred different topics but handlers
decide or try to get you to talk about
something you don't really care about
and something really narrow which
doesn't bring out your best nor their
best and that's a frustration but I
think that given an unstructured
three-hour conversation I think it would
be interesting to talk to both I mean
listen with Biden aside from his view on
cannabis or whatever his background and
the incredible unimaginable family
tragedy that he had in his first wife
and you know multiple kids dying and I
mean it
it's just incredible you know and and
with Trump I think also you could have
an interesting conversation yeah those
the human beings with a life story yes
there that uh and they're some of the
most successful humans who have ever
lived to have uh Rose to this highest
office in interesting complex ways yes I
mean one of the things I'm troubled by
maybe you can speak to is why we're so
negative towards presidential candidates
and presidents why
it's just they go through this shitstorm
no matter who they are yeah they're like
hated like all the conspiracy theories
and just
just the Dynamics of how we talk about
them is vicious if you if you just look
at reply Stephen Barack Obama on Twitter
it's like
what is going on here why why because we
look at other leaders in other spaces
and we're generally positive about it
yeah there's a couple different things
there's this Dynamic which is really
unfortunate which is you ask people do
you approve of the job a particular
president is doing and very often if at
any point while they were in office they
did something you don't like people will
say I don't approve and so by its nature
what that means is just like the longer
you're in office the lower your approval
rating is going to be and very often
that's the way it works I mean there's
major events like 911 Spike George W
Bush's approval to a incredible level
then it came back down with the Iraq War
but there's this unfortunate thing that
when when people are just asked you
think Biden's doing a good job if four
months ago Biden did something on health
care that somebody didn't like even if
you like most of it a lot of people from
that point forward will say I don't
approve they might still vote for them
because they like him better than the
alternative or whatever it's it's just
the dynamic of politics and I agree it's
it's very does it have to be that way I
don't think it has to be that way but to
unwind it so many things would have to
change
I think our election system is part of
why politics is the way it is where you
have two choices and it's first past the
post and we have this electoral college
so that depending on which state you
vote in the kind of meaning and
significance of your vote is different
if you vote in Montana it's the
Republican candidates going to win and
that changes the Dynamics I think that's
part of it
um I think that
at a personal level I've experienced
this in my life a lot
we've become and by we I mean people in
the United States to some degree who
talk about this stuff we've become
uncomfortable when there is disagreement
and it bleeds over into now we can't
have a normal interpersonal relationship
anymore I'm from Argentina and in
Argentina it's really common even in my
family there are incredibly heated
political debates at the start the
middle the end of some kind of gathering
but then everybody just goes back to
like okay we disagree on some things but
that's okay and we can now go and you
know finish cooking the beef or whatever
it is that we're doing and I experienced
this even with people who come up to me
on the street and they go just earlier
today a guy came up to me and he said
RFK all the way baby talking about Bobby
Kennedy Jr and I just kind of you know I
said oh all right you know let's see
what happens
and then there was another moment where
the guy ended up standing next to me for
maybe longer than he thought and I could
tell this guy's getting so awkward
because it was an utterance he thought
that would just be on the Fly and he'd
be gone but now we're standing next to
each other waiting for our sandwiches
it's like no big deal you know it's just
oh okay you like Bobby Kennedy Jr I'm I
don't plan to vote for it's fine you
know and that's like a socio-cultural
thing I think there's lots of other
countries I've spent time in uh Italy I
have relatives in Israel we're like
shouting at each other it's sort of like
normal and then you just go back and
finish the it sounds like shouting I'm
sort of exaggerating but very animated
what seem like big disagreements and
then everybody's cool yeah I wish it
were more normal so maybe the mechanism
of going from shouting to being cool
again needs to improve because maybe we
can't solve the shouting at each other
maybe not so maybe we need to somehow
figure out the de-escalation like making
up I've had a few uh recent fights with
friends like that yeah for politics no
oh no but political style emotionally
drenched
stuff and it um it was interesting
to go through that full process and then
make up at the end but it was it was a
process and it was a process that
required being in person and talking
through it
and it was stressful the whole the whole
thing and maybe because most of our
interactions are online we don't get a
chance to do that in person making up
again I don't know but uh do you think
it's a feature or a bug of the system
that we're so we just hate each well the
powerful you mentioned the online part I
think it's if you mentioned it earlier
perfectly which is you take
contentious political issues you create
a platform that rewards controversy and
disagreement and limits the number of
characters you can use to express
yourself you kind of throw it into a
baking dish and and you know mix the
entire thing up it's complete in total
chaos and one of the things that you
know I've talked before about all the
angry emails and threats and stuff that
I get I'm acutely aware that if I had
in-person conversations with most of
these people
the conversations would basically be
like oh we have different views about
how to solve some of the problems we're
facing we probably agree about what the
problem is
and we probably share many values but on
these particular four issues we may have
very different views
that's okay
online that's not the case and it leads
to you know the the mess mess that we
get ourselves in but I think that it's a
feature of a lot of the systems that are
being used to disseminate information